e
[Silence]
alhamdulillah
m
[Silence]
feab Islam
s
[Silence]
for for
continuing in the chapter of authored
by the chapter regarding
the
stages
that the legislation of Islam took the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
the companions through with regards
to opposition
those who opposed the prophet sallallah
alai wasallam those who
opposed the companions those who
opposed
Islam they
were of two main types there were
those who
opposed and were antagonists of Islam
and the
Muslims
outwardly from outside and then there
were those who opposed Islam from the
inside
a kind of fifth column if you will these
were the Hypocrites these are referred
to as
Hypocrites in the
Quran Allah subhanahu wa
taala first commanded the prophet s.
wasam to
recite he was not commanded at that
point to invite anyone to Islam though
he did informed khad he did
inform he informed those who were close
to him and his confidants Allah
subhanahu waala then sent to him
commanding him in to stand and
Warn and so he did so and this was in
stages the first
stage was that he warned outwardly those
who were closest to him of his
tribesmen and
then the next stage the following stage
was that he
called all of the people of quray to
Islam another stage was that he called
all of the people of Mecca and those who
were on the outskirts of Mecca and the
neighboring Villages and cities
then he was commanded
to Warn and call and invite to Islam
and spread Islam to everyone the Arab
peninsula after which he was commanded
to invite all to Islam
anywhere his Messengers could
reach he spent 13 years in Mecca without
any without any
violence being used without any physical
defense he was not permitted to he
and the companions were not permitted to
fight even in defense of their own
selves as official Jihad nothing that is
beyond the scope
of beyond the scope of self-defense
on an individual
level he was commanded to be patient
with his opposition his
antagonist then he was permitted to make
hij after which he was permitted to
fight then he was commanded to fight
those who fought against him then he was
commanded to
fight
until the affair was to the discretion
and to the law of Allah subhanahu wa
taala meaning that anywhere the Muslim
State the Muslim empire could reach the
law of Allah was implemented doesn't
mean people were forced to become Muslim
but it does mean that the laws of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala were then
regulated throughout
the the land those who wish to remain
and retain their respective religions
then they have the permission to do
so they have the permission to do so and
they pay a tax and those who are Muslim
they don't pay this tax because they pay
zaka and
so those who pay this tax this gizia
they
receive protection they receive
citizenship
essentially and they receive a lot of
the services that are a Ed to the rest
of the
population so it's not just a mere tax
however there has to be a level of
adherence to the
law and within that law they are
permitted to practice their
religion and they're permitted to retain
their
religion a person may say
well is it
permissible for them to make alcohol
alcohol is prohibited in Islam is it
permissible for them the Muslim state to
produce or import alcohol we say no this
is an illegal substance in the time of
the Prophet sallallahu alaih wasallam
after its
prohibition this is not part of
practicing a religion there is no
religion that is a a
u that is
a recognized
religion that commands anyone to drink
alcohol this is something that is
prohibited for the betterment of the
society this is there is a difference
between being allowed to do what you
want and practicing your religion
practicing your religion means that they
are permitted to retain their faith
their beliefs their Services whatever
it is in their respective
communities but it doesn't mean that for
a Muslim you have laws and for a
non-muslim you have a separate set of
laws regarding or pertaining to them
that's not how that works so when
alcohol was
prohibited the Muslims were the first to
stop the production the importation
exportation of alcohol Etc just any
illegal substance in any major
country which concerns itself with the
well-being of its
citizens now if we look at
countries such as
America there was Prohibition
prohibition error in the 20s this
happened why did this happen why did
this
why did it come to
pass that the American government and
the majority of its citizens or a
majority of its citizens decided that
alcohol was to be prohibited the answer
is because it was an objective decision
it absolutely
destroys
any society that it becomes a part
of it destroys it
we may look around us and think well you
know I don't see it being so bad it
looks regulated it's
not millions of people are killed from
drunk driving millions of people are
raped every year or hundreds of
thousands there
are some estimates place it at about 35
to
40% of all people incarcerated in
America it has something to do with
alcohol either they were drunk or the
victim was
drunk more than 30% of all violent
crimes are propelled alcohol was
involved along with other things like
alcohol poisoning liver failure
all of these things that become a
huge burden upon the society so someone
can enjoy himself how many ille
illegitimate
babies how many how many times are
people unfaithful to their spouses how
many times the people kill themselves
by accident because they're drunk how
much money is wasted and we're speaking
now about criminal law what about
civil law how much property is dis
damaged and destroyed because of
alcohol how many accidents how much of
the wildlife or the city or the
infrastructure is damaged because of
alcohol etc etc we could go on all day
the fact of the matter
is is
that trying to defend something the
consumption of
alcohol as a law and protect it it's an
unwinable argument
objectively right the laws of Islam they
are not just Helter Skelter arbitrary
laws in order to control the population
these are not the this is not the
mission of Islamic law so yes
non-muslims lived they were allowed to
retain their faith in the Muslim State
they pay a tax just any other major
state that has any kind of social U
responsibilities to its
citizenry and the prohibitions of
Islam become the
prohibitions of those who live in the
Muslim in the Muslim state in the Muslim
region and these prohibitions which are
general prohibitions which are
prohibitions which are
enforcable right these prohibitions are
only for the betterment of the society
either for the general well-being or for
individual well-being as
well so alcohol was never a
part of anyone's religion we need to
drink alcohol in order for this in order
for us to Worship in our religion right
right or many other things that are
prohibited and the yard stick is not
well as long as you're not hurting
anybody it's okay this is a silly way of
of
rationalizing things that are lawful and
things that are unlawful and it's a it's
a very it's a very hypocritical way of
speaking as well what how do we gauge
hurting what is
hurting is hurting
just shedding someone's
blood what about when
you
you know what about when you cheat
on your spouse adultery does that hurt
anybody it doesn't physically kill
people I mean in many cases it may lead
to that does it hurt
anyone so this gauge of as long as it
doesn't hurt anyone is kind of a cheap
cop and it cheapens the conversation it
cheapens the
discussion he tells us
that after the permissibility
of using arms taking up arms in
defense of General well-being of the
state and in order to further its
interests those who who refrained from
entering into Islam were of three
types the first
was those who
had
a
treaty the second
was those who refus to have a treaty
with the Muslim with the Muslims and
refuse to become a part of the
state so
they were kind of Rebel
tribes a third
was those who remained upon their
respective Faith but they became a part
of the Muslim State a larger Muslim
State and so the pro the prophet
sallallah alai wasam was commanded by
Allah to uphold the
treaties all
treaties that were arrived at and
agreed upon as long as those treaties
were upheld by the other
end by the other party by the other
tribe by the other
side and the prophet sallai was was
commanded that if he
feared that they were going to prove
treacherous with their treaty that he
is to Proclaim to them and send notice
to them that their treaty is no longer
binding and Allah subhanahu waala
commanded the prophet s. wasam to fight
those who to respond with fighting
against those who did not fulfill and
honor their
treaty and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
sent down the chapter Surah which was
revealed around the 9th year after hij
this was in the very late stages of the
Muslim State we see that Allah subhanahu
wa taala placed a lot of these laws and
regulations
inah speaks about battle it speaks about
fighting it speaks about the types of
Believers the types of disbelievers
and primarily focuses on the various
antagonists of
Islam those who are outwardly
antagonistic and those who are
antagonizing Islam from the from the
inside so there there are those who are
overtly aggressive and then there are
those who are passively
aggressive passively aggressive this is
hypocrisy this is exactly what hypocrisy
is and this is how it's defined in our
modern culture passive aggressiveness
and passive aggression is the
methodology of the
Hypocrites
technically they were not aggressive
technically they didn't show any
aggression right so
technically they didn't do
anything but everyone
the game here clearly sees what is
happening this is the methodology of
Hypocrites who do not to face their
enemies
outward and are more prone to lie and
wait and are more prone to treachery
Allah subhanahu waa
[Silence]
subh
and
[Silence]
subhah
ISL
[Silence]
subh
subhah
[Silence]
for
Islam for
[Silence]
subhah
for for
[Silence]
you say
for for
[Silence]
f
Fe
[Silence]
and so when we look at this statement
here of we're spending a lot of time on
this because honestly a lot of these
things are taken out of context all of
the time they're taken out of context
purposly by a lot of people who are
antagonists of Islam who wish to
articulate some kind of vulgar imagery
about Islam that Islam and especially
the Islam of the time of the Prophet
sallallah alai wasam the Muslims didn't
get better with time the further they
got away from the sunah of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam that early
most pure generation the more we lost
our position the more vulgar Our Lives
became speaking about especially the
first generation which is what this
book's subject is topic of this book is
the messenger of Allah Muhammad s
andah people cherry-pick verses from the
Quran they cherry-pick narrations from
the Sun of the Prophet sallallah alai
wasam from books of
Hadith and they cherick these things and
they put them all
together and they try
to articulate
in the mind of a listener very vulgar
bloodthirsty imagery of the Prophet s.
wasam and his
companions to the point that many
Muslims feel shy to even discuss about
this they feel you know don't push
too far because you know we'll run out
of
arguments there is absolutely
nothing to be ashamed of about Islam the
world has never before nor will ever
after see the kind of justice and light
and
guidance and
so we see that the prophet
Sall as tells us he was commanded to
fight against the people of the book
until they hand over or they give over
the
gizia what is alizia is tax upon those
who wish to retain their
faith their respective faiths they do
not enter into Islam they wish to accept
their keep their respective faiths
but they wish to remain a part of the
Muslim State the
Muslim whole there's a lot of things to
benefit from
that if Muslim rule was so
terrible it would not have lasted 1,400
years
if it was so terrible especially to many
of the people of the book the Jews
Christians and non-muslims in general as
long as they are not aggressive
combatants overly overtly aggressive or
violent they will live a respectable
life amongst the Muslims but we have to
remember the
context when we look at the verse for
instance in Surah
which commands
Al look at this verse we see the wording
is a little bit harsh it could come off
harsh and taken at face value it seems
to be
overtly oppressive however when we
understand its context there's nothing
oppressive about it first of all we have
to understand as
Muslims that the Message of
Islam the pure Message of Islam not any
Distortion that was added on by human
beings but the Islam that the prophet
sallallah alai wasallam came
with he himself the Quran and
Islam these
are things which are
irrefutable irrefutable
the arguments of
Islam whether it be
logical
natural
deductive
inductive they are irrefutable
arguments irrefutable
arguments those who decided
to reject the prophet
alam's
message and they Reed the message as it
was and most of them received or saw or
interacted with the prophet Muhammad
Sall alaih wasallam
himself none of them disbelieved because
they were not
convinced there's no way that you're
going to meet a messenger of Allah or be
familiar with the book book of Allah the
Divine words of Allah in its proper
context properly in the way that it was
presented and not be convinced this is
just not it it doesn't
exist people don't admit this obviously
because nobody is going to say I refuse
this because I'm too arrogant to follow
it or I'm too coward to follow it or I'm
to people don't say that obviously
they say all kinds of things just
was told to prostrate to Adam right
simple enough who told him
Allah where in Paradise amongst the
Angels
right he did not he refused to do it why
did he refuse he refused out of
arrogance he refused out of arrogance
however when Allah asked him and he is
all knowing subh why did you refuse he
didn't say because I'm too arrogant even
in dealing with Allah who there's it's
chewing water there's no point in
lying at this point because that which
is hidden and that which is exposed are
equally known to Allah subhanahu waala
yet what was his response well I'm
better than him I was created from fire
and he was created from dirt so you know
I don't see the logic in prostrating to
him flimsy argument didn't convince a
single soul not even himself no one was
convinced by this
obviously everyone has an
excuse for not doing the right
thing merely having an excuse is not
good
enough and so this is something that we
have to understand
there is no
one who met the prophet Muhammad s.
wasam heard his message and understood
it and genuinely understood it and
rejected it because they were genuinely
confused this person doesn't exist in
history the argument that Allah is the
creator the sustainer the one who gives
the one who takes the the the originator
the one who answers the calls of those
who call upon him the one who has
decreed and knows that which is in front
and behind his
creation and that Allah subhanahu waala
alone without any Partners is the only
one worthy of
worship none other is worthy of of
worship in any fashion in any color or
form or
shape but Allah subhanahu waala these
are arguments that are irrefutable the
Quran is the words of Allah from Allah
subhanahu wa taala not the words of any
human being or any group of human beings
or any group of
creatures these are arguments which can
be made they can be claimed but they
hold no
weight it's we say a a how of
cards if you
will and
so those who have met the prophet
Muhammad s. wasam and
rejected Islam they rejected
it out of arrogance this arrogance or
weakness you know we look at Abu J Abu J
rejected it out of arrogance we looked
at Abdullah Sal the head of thef in
Medina he rejected it out of
jealousy we look
at one of
the one of the governors of the Roman
Empire he rejected it why out of fear of
losing his
kingship and many scholars mention that
he initially did become Muslim but then
when he gathered with his Senate and he
gathered with with his advisers and
you know propositioned them brought up
the idea of accepting Islam when he
received the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam letter and he knew all the
signs he asked them they became very
angry they tried to leave he had locked
the door so that they couldn't get away
and he said I was just testing
you it was just a test I want to make
sure that you guys are not going to give
in strong
faith and he died upon that we have no
recorded person who is genuinely
confused a genuinely confused person is
not eligible for punishment by Allah
subhanahu wa taala this is why Allah
subhanahu wa taala
describes himself and he says we would
never
punish
anyone until we send a messenger to
them and he says subhanahu waala all of
these
Messengers we have sent them as bearers
of glad tidings and
Warners so that no one would have have
an excuse in front of
Allah so there's no one who genuinely
misunderstood The Message of Islam a
person who genuinely misunderstands this
person hasn't has not seen Islam
correctly and
so when we are dealing with this kind of
situation there are
people who wish to reject the duties of
Islam
but they want to accept the fruits of
Islam this is not going to be
allowed it's if I'm living here in
America and I say no I
want tax returns but I don't want to pay
taxes I want the services all the
services that are allotted to to
everyone but I refuse to pay a single
dime in taxes
it's the same kind of attitude this
would not be tolerated anywhere
obviously not individually and not in
groups of people and certainly not from
a government standpoint because if you
allow this kind of thing to Fester will
turn into Rebellion that is inevitable
history has clearly shown us
that and so there are those who refuse
to enter into Islam but they want they
didn't want the responsibility of
Islam but they wanted to keep their life
how it was but they wanted
to partake in the Bounty of Islam and
its
establishment
and this is not something that is
going to be just that if a person
wishes to be a citizen of any place they
have to contribute in order to
receive
the fruits and benefits of that
Collective of
people and Medina and the Islam the
state of the Muslims the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and his
companions no are no
different and for this reason people
many people entered into
Islam outwardly inwardly They didn't
accept
it tells us
that the prophet s. wasam would give
people who were new to Islam so much
wealth that sometimes he would give a
man an entire Valley full of
livestock just for becoming
Muslim to the point where a man would go
back to his
people and
say and and tell them to become Muslim
because because Muhammad is giving out
so generously it's he has no
concept of poverty he has no fear of
poverty
whatsoever very
freehanded
and tells us that a man would come into
Islam everyone knows clearly he is only
here for to reap the
fruits with the Muslims however he would
spend only a small fraction of
time and his heart would then pull be
pulled in to Islam the world would be
meaningless to him after
that
because of
the beauty that they would find and
discover of themselves and others in
Islam so those who wish to remain must
remain upon their
religion and remain within the Muslim
State they would have to pay a tax which
is
absolutely
the only logical thing there's not
something that's going to be an
obligation upon the Muslims that's not
an obligation upon non-muslims as well
we will stop there today
[Silence]
Allah